ceux qui vivent ces mauvais les taux des
quatre taxes à l'état fait tout ce que
vous voulez que les bonnes vaches coupé
s'il vous plaît coupe
vous n'êtes pas une tablette pour faire
mon tour le cap nous y regarder il fait
montre les cartes
oh non mais franchement écoute rennes
mais écoutez gars et en russe me faire
une [ __ ] aurait fait deux tours canons
allez faites moi un troisième tour aux
radiations faible non parce qu'il est
passé à l'automne ou vtt allez vous
reposer
et si on se retrouve ce créateur
d'accord vraiment à l'endroit des pages
on avait le kaléidoscope vers côté à
2009 aux pros et l'énigme à 2002 que tu
avais vraiment et c'est toute la journée
comme ça chez chaque samedi
alors
programme de demain avec vous de nous
comme toutes les idées autour de nous
depuis tout à l'heure
j'aimerais arriver à garder notre
sérieux jusqu'à la fin alors vous avez
le choix pour le caler notre copie j'ai
jamais arrivé côté n'a vraiment pas
alors à 12h30 les bonnes coupes
parfaites comme ça d'après midi un
programme destiné à nos jeunes familles
le viking
et puis la case de l'oncle tom
voilà je vous souhaite une très bonne
nuit % flore j'espère au moins que notre
regretté vous aura mis en joie
le prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
de may 13 heures avec jean pierre
pernaut
bonsoir passé une très bonne soirée
alors vous avez le choix
les deux copains qui n'a vraiment pas
alors à manger où ça à béthune gérard
oui de lise
un premier concurrent et bien ce sera à
trouville
madame raymonde das ville raymonde
bonjour quel est votre soirée monde 1500
francs raymond a quoi pensez vous je
porte à la présentation d'une élection
un kir pas dans ta nation plutôt une
maman madame parfaite en guerre comme ça
madame marie qu'un outil qui habite
ajaccio en corse
marie bonjour oui je pense à la mort
dont bal taquin baldaquin non ce n'est
pas un baldaquin marie béthune dans le
pas-de-calais madame claudie boulanger
claudie bonjour j'ai fait beaucoup
la très communicatif je permets de vous
dire que vous êtes encore plus un peu
plus votre bonheur
mais vous savez mais ils font n'importe
quoi
en tout cas je vous remercie beaucoup
madame que choisissez-vous le
kaléidoscope oui allons j'avais pensé à
3,20 c'était pas pour toujours je la
joue là écrivent enfin ce partout au pij
ou de la couronne pour quatre premiers
noms non madame mais pas ça mathieu
maxime fois de poitiers maxime bonjour
avez vous choisi maxime pardon oui ça
n'est pas ça nico choisissait bull a
maintenant très bien alors le
kaléidoscope et patrese 1500 francs
pardon à bon escient car s'il est
célibataire
madame marie claire des veaux qui habite
bonnet dans la saône et loire
marie-claire bonjour votre choix marie
claire marie claude alors non
marie-claude ça n'est pas un tissu de
cachemire merci monsieur stéphane ados
stéphane bonjour vous retenir qu
avez-vous choisi s'était fait recaler
des scop annoncé c'est un ensemble
d'oiseaux qui servait aux indiens comme
chapeaux sont des plumes khiter but
attendu pour répéter oui c'est un
ensemble des plus de 3o qui servait aux
inquiets quand chapeau non c'est pas ça
c'est pas ça c'est pas festif m madame
yvonne pas exempt ils veulent bonjour
bonjour d'ennemis enfin alors oui le
kaléidoscope oui alors je pense cargo
cuit dans un petit plat ça n'est pas ta
madame suzanne open et ouais pas venir à
l'eau qui êtes vous pour madame
que choisissez vous le kaléidoscope
alors il est à 13 milles 5
alors je pense à un costume un marque
effectivement non ce n'est pas non plus
un masque d'esquimaux merci beaucoup
madame monsieur georges trans il est
bonjour messieurs bonjour d'année
continue
pardon madame je choisis le khalife des
records oui je pense à la carte partait
le crachat
jours qu'il a été investi point locale
non ce n'est pas ça merci beaucoup mais
ça me passe à madame danièle jilet
daniel bonjour qu avez-vous choisi oui
alors je pensais à l'amour et qui se
trouve à l'intérieur de l'église miniato
à la montée de la région plus rempli non
dans les bassins l'umq monsieur didier
là qu'est didier bonjour pendant tout ce
temps elle est montée à 2100 francs
cette énigme voulez vous que je vous
rappelle la question didier les
frontières naturelles de cette île
mystérieuse ont été empruntés à quatre
pays différents
quelles sont ces pays mais c'est ce que
j'ai dit on plaît ou pas vous choisissez
l'énigme ou le kaléidoscope oui on a
numéroté les les pays alors à quoi
pensez-vous monsieur même le papillon
non ça n'est pas ça madame brigitte
dupont
brigitte bonjour vous plaît oui j'ai cru
que je porte à une une couronne de caen
non ce n'est pas une couronne de compte
une aventure madame bonaventure belle
aventure pour allô allô
comment vous appelez-vous monsieur je
vois la voiture aulas
que choisissez vous monsieur je vous
rappelle la question des frontières
naturelles de cette île mystérieuse a
été emprunté à quatre pays différents
quelles sont ces pays il ya quatre pays
monsieur non ça fait 5 mais de toute
façon ça n'est pas ça monsieur
merci beaucoup j'ai le un concurrent
encore gérard et bien c'est monsieur
jean mans manassé liant ninon banon a
dit m c'est un petit tout ce qu'ils
fassent ce qu'il faut en face
alors non excusez-moi mais je ne nous
n'avons plus le temps alors en tout cas
pour jouer avec nous il faut nous écrire
sur cartes postales votre nom votre
numéro de téléphone et l'indicatif de
votre département et nous envoyer cette
carte postale à et maintenant je
montrais d'aix 475,3 s'emparer bruit
voilà eh bien c'était notre dernier jeu
de l'après midi oui mais en tout cas moi
je avec mercier
je remercie je vous remercie tous les
deux de m'avoir autorisé
merci mort a beaucoup ri parce qu'il
comprend toujours pas ce qui se passe je
vous comprends pas le kaléidoscope pour
lui c'est d'une année
edit c'est vers ça brille alors s'en
fout alors que celles concernant cette
année mais howard carter alors massa
site raconte tout à fait à dessein par
exemple 8 2 il fera 45 secondes là parce
qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de temps très
bien vous allez voir le trac at-il vous
sortez d'où sort le 18 4
ça me rappelle quelque chose il avait
déjà fait mais qu'il y avait aussi
beaucoup de lettres des enfants qui
voulaient le voir ce qu'ils disaient
qu'il était né locales dans la main qui
était trop petit qui voyait pas ville
alors oui je vais le faire une nouvelle
fois qu il a payé vous expliquer les
tricots mais au fait oui fait comme ça
maintenant qu'on sait c'est vite fait il
pas comme ça y est tous pas regarder on
souffre
il a capté ils sortent tous envoyé à
l'homme sa masse pas ah oui ça marche et
ça coupe tout seul voilà les tracas qui
sont sortis il y en a ne naîtra alors
exceptionnellement puisque moi explique
via mail est une mesure socialement et
où s'explique électrique voulez le
savoir assez siècle c'est très facile
c'est pas moi qui fais les tricks
regarde bien c'est pas moi qui le fais
vous intéresser je les vendais takita
d'akita qu'il faut les taux c'est pas
moi oui si vous accédez match charmant
voulait non merci non non sont des
signes qui ne réagissent pas non me
coûter un cadre qui souffrent projet toi
merci mon cher josé tous nos compliments
cher de nilza effet gagné aujourd'hui un
téléspectateur
et puis vous avez gardez votre sang
froid si j'ose m'exprimer racing kraft
22 ans prestigieuse est terminée elle
recommencera samedi prochain à la même
heure si tout va bien vers 14h05 14h08
bon week-end sur tf1 au revoir